was for many argentines a man from
another time and another place
he was born in the remote mountainous
northwestern province of la rioja
to syrian immigrant parents
became governor of his home province in
1973
representing the peyronie's party
founded by the former president juan
peron
he adopted the style with his couch
address and wide sideburns of 19th
century rural heroes
and brought to buenos aires flamboyance
and panache
mixing with showbiz and sporting
celebrities and driving fast cars
he came to power in 1989 as argentina
was suffering hyperinflation
with his influential economics minister
domingo cavallo
he implemented a plan credited with
ending the economic crisis
along with large-scale privatization of
state industries
his second term in office saw rising
unemployment and increasing social
discontent
a prisoner during military rule he
helped steer argentina from brutal
repression
although some criticized him for making
too many concessions
to those same repressors
[Music]
he failed to change the argentine
constitution limiting him to two
consecutive terms in office but run for
the presidency again
in 2003 standing down before the second
round of voting
when it became clear hit lose to the
eventual president nestor kirchner
menem was no stranger to controversy
convicted of smuggling weapons to
croatia and ecuador
and investigated on various corruption
charges
he'll be remembered with mixed emotions
by argentines who lived through the
1990s
one thing they will all agree on however
life with carlos menema's president
was never dull